- All rise for the...
-
de délibération, le jury
est parvenu à un verdict.
Il s'est en silence que
les trois hommes accusés
ont écouté le juge.
Travis McMichael, son père Greg,
et leur voisin William Bryan
sont reconnus coupables
de
dont celui de meurtre.
"Nous le jury, dit le juge,
coupable de meurtre."
C'i i i i qui a ouvert le feu
après une altercation avec
le jeune afro-américain
dans le quartier.
oioioiois hommes pourchassaient
en voiture le jeune homme,
affirmant qu'ils l'avaient
qui rodait dans le voisinage.
Tous les trois ont été
reconnus coupables et
DiDiDiDites son nom, Ahmaud
Arbery," scande la foule
à l'extérieur du tribunal.
des manifestations antiracistes
durant l'été 2020. D'autant plus
que les trois hommes avaient
été arrêtés, près de
seulement lorsque des images
du meurtre, filmées par
l'un d'entre eux, avaient
été diffusées.
Le poing levé, main dans
la main avec les parents
de la victime, les ténors
des droits civiques
le verdict.
"Il faut que le monde sache
qu'un jury de 11 Blancs et
"Il faut que le mhehehehehe
un Noir, dit-il, dans le Sud
debout pour dire que la vie
des Noirs compte."
Les avocats de la défense
iront en appel, tout en
judiciaire fonctionne bien.
"C'est décevant e,,,,,
dit-il, mais nous comprenons
que c'est une journée
Pour la famille Arbery,
le deuil peut encecececececer.
"Je ne pensais pas que
cette journée arriverait,
vos prières.
Quez est le surnom d'Ahmaud,
ajoute-t-elle, il pourra
maintenant reposer en paix."
Ici, Azeb